monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'économie
il y a un an vous déclariez au sénat je
vous cite nos finances publiques
c'est l'histoire d'une lampe dégradation
depuis 15 ans cette dégradation qui en
trois chiffres 33 3 et 3 vous le voyez
ce n'est pas difficile à retenir 33%
c'est le montant de l'augmentation de la
dette publique en disant propos recensé
l'augmentation de la dette de la dépense
publique 3% c'est également
l'augmentation des taxes et des impôts
et vous ajoutiez ma détermination
personnelle et justement d'en changer
afin que nous dépensions moins et mieux
que nous réduisions par conséquence la
dette
ces propos résonnaient dans l'hémicycle
comme une leçon un tantinet provocatrice
voire même un tant soit peu arrogante et
méprisante
alors monsieur le ministre après le
mouvement des gels et jaune pendant
celui des retraites
je me permets de vous aider à retenir
les chiffres d'aujourd'hui d'une façon
encore plus simple ne retenez plus qu'un
seul chiffre celui de sang la dette est
à 100% du pib le déficit public est à
100 milliards d'euros et vous prélevez
aux contribuables plus de 1000 milliards
d'euros soit 10 fois 100 milliards je ne
pense ne pensez vous pas monsieur le
ministre que la leçon que vous nous
donniez vous avez oublié de vous
l'appliquez
[Applaudissements]